in this video we demonstrate that it's
possible to analyze cardiac pulse from
regular videos by extracting the
imperceptible motions of the head caused
by blood flow recent work has enabled
the extraction of pulse from videos
based on color changes in the skin due
to blood circulation if you've seen
someone blush you know that pumping
blood to the face can produce a color
change in contrast our approach
leverages that perhaps more surprising
effect the inflow of blood doesn't just
change the skin's color it also causes
the head to move this movement is too
small to be visible with the naked eye
but we can use video amplification to
reveal it
believe it or not we all move like
bobbleheads with different motions that
our heart rate but at a much smaller
amplitude than this now you might wonder
what causes the head to move like this
at each cardiac cycle the hearts left
ventricle contracts and ejects blood at
high speed to the aorta during the cycle
roughly 12 grams of blood flow to the
head from the aorta by the carotid
arteries on either side of the neck it
is this influx of blood that generates a
force on the head due to Newton's third
law the force of the blood on the head
equals the force of the head acting on
the blood causing a reactionary cyclical
head movement to demonstrate this
process we created a toy model using a
transparent mannequin head with rubber
tube stands for simplified arteries
instead of pumping blood we will pump
compressed air provided by this air tank
and I can release the air using this
valve now watch what happens as I open
and close the valve once a second
similar to a normal heart rate ready
here this motion is fairly similar to
the amplified motion of real heads that
we've seen before we exploit this effect
to develop a technique that can analyze
pulse and regular videos of a person's
head our method takes an input video of
a stationary person and returns a
one-dimensional signal corresponding to
the head motions from this signal we can
extract an average pulse rate as well as
beat locations for deeper clinical
analysis we begin by locating the face
using a face detector and selecting
feature points within the area the
feature points are tracked from frame to
frame of the video using the
lucas-kanade ii tracking algorithm we
use the vertical or y component of each
of the feature point trajectories for
our analysis
next we temporally filter the signals to
a passband encompassing a normal pulse
range while excluding extraneous motions
like respiration we decompose the
multi-dimensional motion of the head
described by the trajectories into sub
motions using principal component
analysis or PCA PCA returns the main
directions along which the head moves we
project the motion of the head onto each
component and choose the signal with the
clearest dominant frequency we use the
dominant frequency to obtain an average
pulse rate finally we perform peak
detection on the chosen signal to obtain
beat locations for further analysis
such as heart rate variability we tested
our method on different people varying
in skin tone and gender and were able to
get nearly exact pulse rates compared to
an ECG device in addition our method
produce similar beat length
distributions to the ECG an exciting
result that shows that we can capture
more subtle information about the heart
than just an average rate finally our
method is robust to different views of
the head we obtained a pulse from a
sleeping newborn from the back of a
subjects head and even when a person is
wearing a mask
you